this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing all
in one platform
through the link in the description
below more about them in just a bit
for centuries his name has been
synonymous with adventure born
in rural devon so walter rally managed
to rise the very top
of britain's fledgling empire as a
soldier he fought in both france's
religious wars and against the
rebellions in ireland
as a courtier he became one of queen
elizabeth's closest confidants able to
destroy a rival with a whispered word
but rally's roles went beyond what
society expected of him a natural
adventurer he led expeditions to modern
venezuela to find the legendary el
dorado
and funded the establishment of
england's first colony
in the new world but while rally would
think of himself foremost as
an enlightened man they would hand him a
very different guise
that of a political martyr caught on the
losing side of britain's 1603 transfer
of power
rally was imprisoned tortured and forced
to fight
for his very life nearly crushed by the
system he wound up
rolling everything on one final
adventure a daring attempt to wrestle
gold from spain's far-flung
colonies what happened next would ensure
his name lived on
for eternity
[Music]
it's customary for biographies of walter
alley to start by mentioning that he
came from
modest circumstances but make no mistake
his background was
only modest from the point of view of a
16th century
english aristocrat at the moment he was
born in the rural english county of
devon around 1554
rally was almost perfectly positioned
for greatness his aunt
was the governess of the future queen
elizabeth while his half-brother
was humphrey gilbert a seafaring
adventurer whose own life would deeply
influence rallies so while the family
weren't rich they
certainly were well connected but there
was one area where rally's birth put him
at a real disadvantage his family were
hardcore protestants at a time when a
hardcore catholic was on the throne
this meant only one thing persecution
although the family avoided the fate of
other protestants in mary the first's
reign they were still
in constant danger as a result walter
rally would grow up to hold an
undying hatred toward catholics still
their persecution didn't last long
in 1558 mary went off to her eternal
reward and was
replaced by protestant elizabeth first
and just like
that the rallies could breathe easy
again or at least we
assume that was the case in common with
many figures of this era we know
remarkably little
about walter rally's early life in fact
after his birth we can't say with any
certainty what he was doing until
roughly 1569. that's because 1569 is
when the teenage rally left devon to
fight in france's wars of religion
kicking off in 1562 the walls of
religion pitted france's catholic
majority
against its protestant huguenots in an
on-again off-again fight featuring
brutal massacres although he fought in
france for less than a year rally
witnessed enough human depravity
to make a deep impression on him but
probably not
in the way that you might be thinking
when the time came the teenage boy would
himself become
adept at the art of bloodshed fighting
over rally again
dropped out of the historical record
until 1572 when he turned up studying in
oxford
doubtless he made a hell of an
impression there by this time the boy
had grown into a dashing darkhead man
who had six foot
towered over most of his contemporaries
basically he was every young
maiden's dream of a tall dark handsome
stranger with
one exception all his life rally would
speak with a strong
devonshire burr an accent about as sexy
as witnessing a beloved grandparent
dressed in
leather bondage gear still the 1570s
would see rally embark on two
important love affairs the first was
with writing the second
far more important was with exploration
it all started
in june 1578 when rally's seafaring
half-brother sir humphrey gilbert
organized an expedition to try and find
the fabled northwest passage
excited by the prospect rally joined his
siblings fleet as captain of the falcon
only to witness first-hand the
expedition become a disaster scattered
by storms damaged by desertions
gilbert's expedition eventually gave
up on the passage and instead turned to
attacking spanish ships for loot it was
such a failure it could have put
rally off exploring for life but no
something about the high seas the
adventure
the privateering seems to have touched
rally's soul
from that moment on the boy would be
destined for a life
of adventure the first of these
adventures came in the spring of 1580.
jailed for taking part in a brawl rally
got his friends to pull a few strings
and instead have him transferred to the
army's officer corps before he was out
he was in ireland taking
part in the siege of smerwick the
smallwood siege is infamous today
because when the fort surrendered to the
english
they gave no quarter butchering everyone
inside one of those who gleefully
carried out the mass executions
was well to rally in the aftermath of
the massacre rally returned to london
with some secret documents discovered on
the bodies
although he would spend the next year
back in ireland his star was already
beginning to rise he was no longer just
some devon boy with a hankering for
adventure
he was fast becoming a force to be
reckoned with
despite stunning low walls or
gumminger's inbred cousin walter raleigh
never had much trouble with the ladies
although tales of him as a 16th century
james bond with lovemaking skills to
match
later fabrications we know he caught
many a girl's eye
in ireland for instance he sired an
illegitimate daughter but his biggest
catch came
in december of 1581. that was the month
he somehow
turned queen elizabeth said a ton has
been written about the courtship between
walter rally and queen elizabeth the
first with the nature of their
relationship portrayed as
anything from intellectual equals to
definitely sleeping together
certainly rally seems to have wormed his
way into the queen's heart
not long after meeting her he was maiden
squire of the court and
old liz left no doubt that he was her
favorite
on the other hand a lot of the stories
such as rally laying his cloak down so
the queen could avoid stepping in a
puddle almost certainly untrue
sexual or not though rally proved useful
to the queen and
this usefulness paid off big time from
elizabeth's perspective rally was both
an astute courtier writing her
elegant poems and a natural spin doctor
a master of backstabbing of political
cover-ups of
justifying controversial decisions he
also seems to have worked as a secret
agent on occasion such as when the queen
dispatched him to the low countries to
personally retrieve a message from
william the silent
still it'd be hard to claim elizabeth
wasn't a little obsessed with her
new and handsome courtier the gifts
showered on rally would embarrass
a billionaire showing off for his trophy
wife in 1583 rally was gifted the run of
durham house a magnificent mansion
sitting along the strand
that same year the queen bestowed upon
him a monopoly over wine effectively
meaning everyone selling wine in britain
had to pay rally for the privilege
two years later he'd be granted a
similar monopoly on broadcloth plus
a knighthood plus titles like vice
admiral of the west lord lieutenant of
cornwall and
lord warden of the stannaries a fancy
word for cornwall's lucrative tin mines
oh and in 1586 he was also granted 42
000 acres in munster
for his service in ireland about three
times as much as everyone else received
but while rally's rise
at court was dizzying it also changed
him
the more attention elizabeth showed the
more rally started living up to her
image of him as a
dashing flamboyant adventurer he started
dressing extravagantly decking himself
out in pearls acting like he was
constantly performing for an invisible
audience and in a sense he was
later in life rally would write that
it's better to befriend rich people
because only they can give you the money
you need to stand on your own two feet
what was his behavior at court but a way
to ensure that the money kept rolling in
come 1587 rally was established enough
to be made captain of the guard
effectively in charge of elizabeth's
personal protection although he'd have
to wait until 1591 to take up the post
when the current holder died it still
should have been the pinnacle of his
career but by now rally was already
moving on to bigger and better things
no longer content with dreary old
england he had set his sides
on conquering the world and if you want
to conquer a new world it's time to get
help with our friends from squarespace
now more than ever people are getting
creative with their time they're
reaching into their savings account to
start that new
business or they're launching a local
politics blog to share
their opinions with their friends and
neighbors the world is yours and
squarespace is the perfect web tool
to help you show it whatever you like
it's the platform to use when you're
ready to get started on that web project
you've been thinking about
are you looking to get in and out
quickly without thinking too much about
your website and what it should look
like well just use
one of their quick and beautiful
templates to make a website that is
fresh for you or maybe you're more of a
hands-on person and you've got lots of
opinions and ideas about
exactly what your site should look like
squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches
no technical bs to worry about once
you're done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe just playing with some
of the colors
there are so many extra features that
squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive
email campaigns patronage portals social
integrations member-only areas and
customer support it's everything you
could ever want all in one place and
look this isn't just another advertiser
partnership for me when i launched a
website for another channel i do mega
projects megaprojects.net
well of course i use squarespace to make
it and i think i've made an
elegant super functional website and i
really don't have any skills in design
or websites or anything like that it was
all super easy so when you're ready to
get started on the next project of yours
big or small if it involves a website
it's got to be with squarespace right
now you can go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash biographics to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
there's a link below and let's get back
to it
weirdly the best thing that ever
happened to walter rally was probably
his half-brother dying so humphrey
gilbert had been a titan of his age the
sort of guy
we should probably cover in his own
biographics video let us know in the
comments if you want that
as long as he was around rally would
always be content to be in his shadow
a man standing besides greatness rather
than being great himself but in
september 1583 gilbert drowned on an
expedition aged only 43 and simply
standing in his shadow was no longer
possible when rally received the news he
made an important decision he would
carry on with his half-brother's plans
alone at the time of his death gilbert
had been preparing the grounds for a
colonizing expedition to america rally
now picked up those plans and ran with
them assembling a team at durham house
to make them a reality
and so began the story of england's
first colony in the new world
although rally wouldn't physically help
establish it elizabeth being unwilling
to let him stray too far from court
he would both bankroll it and provide
logistics in 1584 that meant supporting
the first scouting mission that sailed
to what we now
call the outer banks of north carolina
and returned with two algonquian
speakers
juanchis and menteo the arrival of these
native americans
in london caused a sensation it's worth
remembering that at this time going to
america
wasn't simple it wasn't even difficult
it was an operation
of bean-dish complexity one account we
read compared it to the apollo program
with
the 1584 expedition being like apollos 7
and 8 basically proving that it could be
done with the success
of that expedition rally and his team
were able to pivot to their own moon
landing
in early 1585 elizabeth granted rally
the title of lord and governor of
virginia
his colony named after the virgin queen
herself that same year an
all-male crew set out to roanoke island
to establish a temporary camp bear that
they could use as a base for future
expeditions it lasted less than a year
before the men gave up and came home
but rally wasn't deterred in spring 1587
the third expedition set out it would be
this expedition
that changed history hundreds of
londoners left on ships that swept
across the atlantic's dangerous waters
the 16th century equivalent of a spacex
fleet
off to colonize mars although it would
be later eclipsed by jamestown the first
colony was
the start of something massive it was
rally's expedition that the seeds of
english north america were sown
that history witnessed the first
glimpses of what would become the usa
from the dizzying heights of the
declaration of independence to the
hideous lows of the trail of tears
everything sprang from this one moment
which is curious when you remember the
rhonic colony
was an abysmal failure despite boasting
the first english child born on american
soil the colony soon ran low on supplies
governor john white was dispatched to
britain to get help only for war
with spain to break out trapping him
across the atlantic by the time white
returned in 1590 the roanoke colony
had been abandoned all that was left was
the word cro-turn
carved in a post a reference to both the
nearby island
and a nearby tribe of the first english
colonists in american history
was no sign back in london rally was
personally blamed for the colony's
failure and the presumed deaths of its
residents
while this isn't really fair it still
left a stain on his reputation that he
struggled to shake off but while being
implicated in the loss of hundreds of
lives wouldn't be
enough to dislodge rally from his
position at the queen's side what came
next
would soon turn him into a pariah it's
time for walter rally
to get married
to this day all sorts of legends still
cling to rally's name for instance
people insist that he introduced both
the potato and tobacco to england
having brought them over from virginia
in reality the potatoes spread across
europe after arriving in spain
while tobacco had reached england as
early as 1571.
at most rally probably made smoking a
fashionable activity
at elizabeth's court yet his fame was so
great
that people would attribute the entire
concept to him but just as odd tales
clung to rallies so too did the man
himself believe
in some wild stuff while this wool might
have been the legend of el dorado
the city of gold that was said to exist
in south america's interior eldorado's
mirage dragged many europeans to their
deaths over the decades
while rally would survive his own hunt
for the city he swallowed the story as
easily
as any conquistador in 1595 even managed
to take four ships up the oronaco river
into modern venezuela in a bid
to get the treasure no prizes for
guessing exactly how much mythical gold
he succeeded in bringing back to england
just a few years earlier rally might
have been able to shrug off such a
failure but by 1595
things had changed from queen
elizabeth's favorite he'd now fall into
a position best described as
most hated man in britain and he'd done
it by breaking the queen's heart
back in 1588 around the time the roanoke
colonists were wondering
where the hell the fresh supplies were
rally started an affair with elizabeth
throckmorton one of the queen's maids of
honor elizabeth better known as
bess was a strong-willed woman who was
easily rallies equal
sadly that sort of instant attraction
didn't count for much when the queen
herself was
fawning over rally and the two were
forced to keep their repair secret which
was all fine
and dandy until bess fell pregnant in
1591
determined to do the decent thing rally
married bess in secret and
they both kind of just hung around the
edges of the court whistling
nonchalantly and
hoping no one would notice the brand new
baby it was a dream
as quixotic as finding eldorado in may
of 1592 word of the marriage and the
baby finally got back to the queen who
detonated with the force of a thousand
hiroshimas
rally and bez were arrested and thrown
into the tower of london it was only
when rally
bribed the queen with insane amounts of
treasure that she agreed to release him
but by then it was too late the baby
died the same year it was born
never knowing a normal family life
although bess was likewise released in
the wake of the tragedy both she and
rally were banned from court their names
reduced to mud still rally was convinced
that this wasn't the end that he could
charm his way back into the queen's good
books
certainly by 1600 elizabeth seems to
have been thawing on him
following a successful attack on the
spanish city of cadiz rally was made
governor of jersey
it seemed like the old rake had done it
that he'd used his endless charm and
talent for adventure to pull
his life back from the abyss alas it was
all just a temporary illusion
elizabeth the first died on march 24
1603 at the age of 69. although her
death wasn't a shock it was still like
someone had placed a bomb under rally's
carefully cultivated life
she'd been his benefactor his protector
even when he was out of favor the queen
had allowed him to
keep his manner and monopolies now she
was gone and suddenly the vultures were
circling
all those people rallied pissed off in
the elizabethan era
by being such a brown noser were out for
revenge
although rally might have assumed he
could turn even this unlucky break
around
he was wrong from now on things were
going to be all downhill
although his rise had taken decades so
walter rally's fall was finished in
barely half a year in the wake of
elizabeth's death james the sixth of
scotland descended to the english throne
as james the first already
ill-disposed towards annoying
adventure-loving fops
when rally first met the new king he
received less a smile than
an unimpressed grimace still rally was
at least allowed to perform his official
functions at elizabeth's funeral but it
was
just a final nod to the departed queen
the moment his benefactor was in the
ground rally's life
spectacularly imploded he was thrown out
of his mansion of two decades durham
house given
barely a fortnight to plan his move then
he was stripped of his role as captain
of the guards before
losing the right to both his monopolies
it was a humiliating reversal of fortune
a kick in the nuts from fate that
rally felt was wholly undeserved
unfortunately though
this was just the beginning to
understand what happened next we need to
quickly introduce a couple of characters
george and henry brooke were
aristocratic brothers with
henry being both the 11th baron cobham
and a close friend of rally they were
also suspected of involvement in two
utterly hare-brained schemes known
as the bi plot and the main plot to
kidnap king james and either force him
to make pro-catholic declarations or
just sell him as a prisoner to spain
when the biplot was discovered in july
of 1603 george brooke was duly arrested
only to implicate both his brother and
walter rally as co-conspirators
likely brooke was just throwing out
names trying to buy himself some
leniency but the guards arrested both
rally
and the baron cobham it was here that
rally made his fatal mistake
realizing he too might be tortured he
wrote a vague letter to the privy
council
saying that he'd always thought his
friend the baron was a bit suspicious
and he should have reported it earlier
rather than release rally the council
showed the letter to cobham who
immediately flipped into full kamikaze
mode
declaring himself guilty cobham also
told his interrogators that rally was
the plot's ringleader although cobham
retracted his confession a few days
later the damage had been done
rally was sent to trial in november that
year things looked so bleak that he
tried to commit suicide in his cell
by stabbing himself when that failed he
was dragged through the streets of
london
and out to face the judges winchester
it's a mark of how far
rally's stock had fallen that the guards
didn't think that he'd make it to the
trial
the crowds in london tried to lynch him
throwing rocks and abuse cursing rally's
name
by the time he made it to winchester
rally was a shell of a man frightened
damaged caught up in a legal system
determined to find him guilty
which is what makes what happened next
so impressive on the day of his trial
november 17
1603 rally sat in a packed courtroom
before a panel of
biased judges and systematically
demolished them
using his incredible learning rally was
able to quote precedents from english
law that showed the evidence was too
flimsy to convict him
when that failed he pivoted to creating
watertight cases from logic
and common sense when the judges
dismissed them he made a scholarly plea
based on biblical law the crowd
absolutely ate it up
rally had walked into that chamber one
of the most hated men in britain
by the end of the day he had his enemies
eating out of his hand
it helped that he had a talent for drama
such as his ending flourish when
he produced a new secret confession
written by cobham that exonerated rally
but impressive as rally's hand was he'd
overplayed it
with what we can only imagine was the
slightest smile in history the judge
produced an even newer confession from
cobham
that basically said lol the confession i
gave to rally is fake
he's totally guilty and with that walter
rally realized that his ace in the hole
had been nothing more
than a dog-eared joker that same day
rally was convicted and sentenced to
death a penalty to be carried out as
swiftly and as nastily as possible
but while his sentence would indeed be
carried out there would be nothing swift
about it
nobody in that crowded courtroom in 1603
could have guessed it but rally wouldn't
be executed
for another 15 years
if you've ever wondered what life in the
tower of london was like you probably
assumed it involved adjectives like
nasty and short but not where wall
torelli was concerned
after his public performance at trial
james the first felt leery about
executing someone so popular
instead he had the adventurer locked
away in what we can only describe
as luxury rally was not only given two
rooms in the tower but a garden for
exercise a
place to keep his laboratory and
unlimited visits from his wife he was
even allowed to write composing his the
history of the world
all while not just imprisoned but
technically dead yep
dead although james couldn't bring
himself to actually kill rally he still
had him declared legally dead
rally though was already planning his
resurrection this wasn't a plan to
physically escape the tower
no he wanted to walk out a free man to
be pardoned by
james to go back to being a favorite
rally realized there was only one way to
drag himself to the very top again
he was going to have to find eldorado
from our 21st century perspective we
know
this plan was the dictionary definition
of bananas eldorado
didn't exist it was just a legend
conquistadors believed in to
justify all the hardship and genocide
rally might as well have gambled
everything on discovering an unlimited
supply of cheese on the moon
in the early 17th century though it was
much more believable the spanish were
already bringing silver back from the
new world at a crazy rate
why couldn't england get in on that
action in 1616
king james finally agreed to release
rally for him to go and look
for eldorado but there would be
conditions the first was that rally
would be watched closely to stop him
simply hightailing it to france the
second was the rally must not
repeat not antagonize the spanish who
james was trying to live peacefully with
it was this last condition that would
seal rally's fate rally's expedition
left plymouth in june of 1617 arriving
in south america that november
the plan was to sail up the oronarcos
through spanish territory
and into the interior at the last moment
though rally came down with fever and
had to stay on a boat at the river's
mouth while
his men did all the exploring that would
turn out to be very
very unfortunate rally's troop sailed up
the river and almost immediately
attacked and looted the spanish
settlement of santhon
failing to find eldorado they instead
panicked and burned the settlement and
then
turned around and hightailed it back to
england and that was it for rally's
last desperate shot at redemption the
fleet reached plymouth in mid-1618 to
discover word of the massacre had beaten
them home
the moment rally stepped off the boat he
was arrested initially held in west
country he twice tried to escape to
france and when that failed he
wrote a pamphlet trying to whip up
anti-spanish sentiment
by now he'd pissed off king james for
the last time that october james
convened a special panel of judges to
ask if there was a legal basis for
reinstating rally's 1603 sentence of
execution
long story short the judges said yes on
october 29 1618 walter rally was led out
to the scaffolding
there he made a 45-minute speech
summarizing his career
and asking for the crowd to pray for his
soul then he knelt down
closed his eyes and the executioner
swung his axe
it took two blows to sever rally's head
once the deed was done
his wife best demanded the head be
placed in a velvet bag till her dying
day
bess would carry that bag with her
wherever she went at the moment of his
death so alta rally was probably one of
the most interesting figures in british
history
while he'd done a lot of adventuring and
risen from a rural background to the top
of london society it also
died having failed to either establish a
north american colony
or discover eldorado yet from our
vantage point we can see
that his failure was only temporary even
before he died rally was living in a
world in which england had a permanent
colony in america
just like the one he'd envisaged less
than two years after his execution the
mayflower pilgrims would leave plymouth
for the new world and
history would change forever of course
there's only so much credit we can give
rally for
all these later colonies after all his
roanoke failed spectacularly
yet still it was walter rally who did it
first who pioneered a concept that would
reshape
the entire world it was a concept he
failed at but one
that laid the groundwork for all that
came after if that's what failure looks
like
and we can judge that rally was probably
the most impressive failure
in all of english history so i really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below don't forget to subscribe
also please do check out our fantastic
sponsor squarespace who i'm linking to
below
and thank you for watching